if there's one motion design technique
that applies to everything its easing
that's what gives objects their wobble
their bounce and makes rigid lifeless
animations like this feel more natural
and real like this
so let's look how we can liven up your
motion graphics with easy
[Music]
let's jump into all the theory with a
bit of animation 101 the basics of
animation is having a property be it
scale rotation position whatever and
then setting keyframes for two values at
two different points in our timeline as
time progresses between those two
keyframes the value changes in a process
called interpolation if we graph how the
value changes over time we can see
creates a straight line but if we watch
the actual animation it seems very rigid
and unnatural
that's because objects in the real world
don't move like this weight inertia and
resistance all influence everything
around us and so to make our animations
feel more natural and more real we need
to emulate what these forces might do to
our graph this is where the power of
easing comes in easing changes how our
value changes over time from simply
being a straight line it warps it kinks
it so that even though our value is
still traveling between the two
keyframes the results are a lot more
dynamic when we talk about easing
between keyframes we have three options
we can either ease in which only affects
our value as it moves from the first
keyframe ease out which affects the
value as we reach our second keyframe or
ease in our which combines the two you
can see how each changes our graph in a
different way the second half of our
terminology for easing usually
references the shape of the graph there
are many ways to describe this and most
do the same sort of thing so
understanding exactly where these names
come from isn't all that important
however there are three that are worth
noting
back is when the value goes slightly
over the intended value and then returns
you can see it gives a line a little bit
of a hump elastic also known as
overshoot is similar but has a decaying
element to it it gives us nice wobble
finally bounces pretty self explainatory
think of a ball it's hitting that hard
value and then bouncing away from it in
a decaying fashion until settling on
that final value now all of these can
apply when easing in easing out or both
practically there's a number of
different ways to create easing in Adobe
After Effects
the easiest of these is right-clicking a
keyframe going to keyframe assistant and
selecting one of the easy ease options
the second is using the graph editor and
using it to manipulate the line between
two keyframes there are two types of
graphs a speed graph and a value graph
you can use the speed graph to influence
the speed of reaching particular values
on your graph
the value graph is where you can
manipulate the actual values have a play
around and see how changing values
influences your animation
another way of easing beyond easy ease
and using the graph editor is by adding
additional keyframes to end in some
dynamics such as keyframing an overshoot
or bounce animation yourself this method
often gives you quicker control over the
look of the resulting animation but
isn't always as clean and as accurate as
other ways finally applying expressions
or scripts to your animation simplifies
the easing process again dan ebbets
motion script site has some great
expressions for bounce and overshoot and
goes into much more depth with how to
use them the link to that page is in the
description below additionally one
plugin I use a lot of is mr. horses
animation composer that gives access to
a number of easing options for position
rotation scale etc with simple controls
that saves me a lot of time when I'm
working on a project for a client saying
all that though the best tool really is
your own eye as you can tell what best
suits your needs for your animation so
that's an overview of easing the
different types there are in the
different ways you can apply them to
your animations visit easing snap for a
quick reference to the various types of
easing there are the link is down below
and leave a comment with your favorite
one or ones that you use until next time
my name is bench thanks for watching
[Music]